Afida Turner, Drake... Excuse-moi, mais
il y a a une collab à faire. Appelez-vous,
je sais pas, contactez-vous.
Salut c'est Shirine Boutella et j'interprète
Jessica Carson dans Pamela Rose, la série.
Salut, c'est Yvick aka Mister V aka SachaSho.
Tu feras un bloopers, une compil.
Salut, c'est Yvick aka Mister V aka SachaSho dans Pamela Rose, la série sur CANAL+.
Ouaaaais, premier coup ! Du premier coup !
Si ça doit pitcher la série, c'est une enquête policière
qui tourne autour d'un meurtre, d'une suite de meurtressur des youtubeurs.
Et nous avons 2 enquêteurs qui mènent l'enquête : Richard Bullitet Douglas Riper,
interprétés par Kad et O, qui sont donc des agents du FBI qui sont un peu sur la fin.
et cette affaire va leur servir de dernière pierre à laquelle se raccrocher.
Mais imaginez unmur d'escalade, tu vas pour tomber, et il ne te reste qu'un galet au mur auquel t'accrocher.
Bah c'est celui-là.
Je suis sûr que vous pensez exactement ce que je pense. Non.
Donc on verra ce qui va sepasser pour eux mais en tout cas, c'est le pitch du début
Super pitch, bravo. Chanmé.
Jessica Carson, c'estla nouvelle du FBI, totalement à l'opposé pour le coup de Kad et O, de Bullit et Riper,
très ambitieuse, très carrée, très smart, très logique...
Blasée d'avoir ces 2 boulets alors qu'elle rêved'avoir une carrière dans le FBI et qu'elle est vachement sûr d'elle et qu'elle sait qu'elle ales capacités et
qu'il y a ces 2 mecs-là en fait qui font n'importe quoi.
Elle se retrouve la seule femmeaussi dans un univers...
la seule femme évidemment, dans un univers assez macho.
Il ne faudra surtout rien dire même
sous la torture. Je sais.
Comment tu t'appelles, bastardo ?
Il y a un lien particulier avecDonuts, le chef, le responsable qu'elle utilise finalement et elle utilise ce côté uncôté très patriarcat de ce mec-là,
qui pense qu'il peut tout lui apprendre.
Je suis un atout toutcourt. Comme vous voulez ma louloute.
Ma quoi ?!
Et au final elle utilise ça pour le manipuler et utiliser tous les mecs autour d'elle...
Shirine, c'est pour les réseaux sociaux ils vont jamais garder toute ta réponse  !
C'est trop long, ils vont jamais tout garder.
Dixit le gars qui met un quart d'heure pour répondreà chaque question.
Bien sûr, bien sûr, mais je le sais...
Donc en fait elle a elle a réussi à utilisertout ça à son avantage
et j'adore, j'ai adoré jouer ce personnage.
Le seul truc- je continue...
Tu peux partir si tu veux.
Non, c'est pas pour moi, c'est pour le monteur !
On se voit ! Mais c'est bien, comme ça ils ont du contenu, ils couperont ce qu'ils veulent.
Tu sais comment ça marche, non ? Je sais qu'il appuie sur L pour faire une avance rapide.
Et SachaSho, tout simplement un youtubeur qui a pour direction artistique de recréer des films entier àl'aide de fruits et légumes.
doc on arrive bientôt attends tu trouves que je vais pas vite si tu
veux je peux appuyer sur le champignon ah merde les champignons c'est assez atypique mais il y
a une communauté qui suit derrière parce qu'il a plusieurs millions d'abonnés mon manque de courage
va faire que je vais à un moment mal'aliier au FBI pour les aider à mener à bien cette enquête
c'était s Sacho et gardz la pêche c'est ce
film là c'est le me rose le premier qui m'a mis
à l'humour moi je suis le plus grand fan de Cadeo
qui existe sur terre la grosse émission tout ce
qu'ils ont fait avant les anthotologies tout ça
je suis gros peut-être un des plus grands fans de
France CAD moi cétait sur le tourage du flambeau
il me dit on fait la série Pamel la rose moi je
lui dis est-ce que je peux jouer un buisson il me
dit bah j'ai peut-être mieux j'ai peut-être des du
texte avec et tout donc incroyable quand je vois
que le rôle est golerie qu'il est en plus du bon
côté dans le sens où je suis un allié de Bullit
riper bah c'est c'est moi les premières scènes
que j'ai joué l'impression d'être dans un rêve
et là je me disis c'est marrant le rêve est réel
et donc c'est vraiment pour le coup moi un un vrai
rêve de gosse je dis pas ça pour les caméra
c'est vrai c'est vraiment mon film de jeev je
peux retrouver je peux retrouver plein j'ai mes
premiers crétrages que je faisais quand j'étais
petit avec le camescope de mon père je repreneaz
des noms qu' avait dedans mais tu pe la rose moi
je ferais pas mieux je suis clairement pas aussi
fan mais j'étais très fan aussi de Cadeo des des
des Kat pamé la rose donc quand j'ai quand mon
agent m'a prop proposais de passer ce casting
là je suis arrivée j'étais comme ça laamb qui
tremblait j'étais hyper impressionné puis j'ai
fait les essais avec eux où en fait on fait on
fait le texte avec eux j'étais hyper intimidée
mais je je voulais tellement ce rôle que je
je me donnais à fond pour essayer de paraître
normal et chill et cool et à la fin en partant
je leur ai dit les gars genre même si je suis
pas prise pour ce rôle c'était juste un bonheur
et un honneur fou de passer cette heure avec vous
et de et de et et d'échanger et faire cette scène
et surtout quand il m'a fait le que en vrai que
ain il est là c'est vraiment ça donc un petit coup
de pression même le premier jour de tournage quand
j'étais avec eu j'étais hyper stressé hyper j'avis
envie de les impressionner en fait tu sais tu as
envie de d'être à la hauteur j'ai raté ma première
prise comme ça j'ai raté ma première prise parce
que je c'était à toiic grave oui pardon parce que
pour moi j'étais en spectateur et c'est très très
dur sur les premières de se lancer parce que tu
te dis ok mince c'est pas un rêve en fait c'est
vraiment la vité donc et puis la première impro
aussi tu as envie de ouais tu bide en fait tu veux
les faire rire B ouais tu veux les faire rire tu
veux tester un truc tu ve te marrer et tu dis ah
ça c'est c'est les c'est les goats et tu peux pas
comme ça te permettre de bon au bout d'un moment
tu en fais et tu vois que ça marche c'est cool
mais il te mettent assez vite à l'aise j'allis
dire en parallèle vraiment ils sont trop trop cool
ils sont tellement bienveillants ils sont ils font
tout pour te t'intégrer te faire sentir à l'aise
et donc ça te met ça ça tout de suite tu sais
tu es à la maison quoi tout que moi j'étais toute
gamine quand je regardais ça quoi encore plus
jeune moi j'étais encore plus jeune moi j'avais
au moins TR 4 ans pourquoi tu penses que j'ai
quel âge je sais pas plus que moi moi je suis
tellement jeune j'ai 30 ans tu es plus jeune j'en
ai 30 ans bah ok ah ok ouais B pareil j'avais le
même âge en moins de 3 ans je TikTok ça me connaît
et je veux une identité temporaire Elvis prley me
c'est cool ça je connais absolument rien d'Elvis
en réalité et je me suis même pas préparé du tout
à faire Elvis parce que je pense que c'est ouais
mais je pense que c'est ça qui fait aussi le le
comic de la situation et c'est Olivier exactement
qui m'a dit en fait FA et il dansait avec mais
moi j'avais jamais réellement connu c'est pas
du tout ma génération je vous rappelle que je
suis un V encore non et depuis peu je suis plus
et non non le Elvis finalement était pas du tout
une mais le créer un mauvais ELV c'était plus ça
me faisait plus marrer justement de pas avoir de
connaissance CLA pour justement pouvoir créer un
personnage un peu immonde qui se veut ressembler
à mais qui n'est pas du tout qui justement crée
le côté décalé c'éit très très très très très
très drôle céit notre première scène ensemble
d'ailleurs dans le bureau de Bull riper où il
a fait justement se déancher j'en pouvais plus
CIT très très très très drôle c'est pas évident
parce que c'était à ce momentl justement quand
on devit je faisais la scène de fin et je vous
regardais dans les yeux je me rappelle et vous
étiez comme ça pas filmé mais vous deviez rester
sérieux et et j'ai vu bah tout le monde se marrer
donc à ce momentlà ça m'a détendu c'est à ce
moment-là d'ailleurs je me suis détendu ouais
ben j'ai dit ah c'est bon on je fais partie du
de l'équipe je suis pas juste un invité surprise
on a un tu à arrêté et la route à prendre
et est-ce qu'on prendrait pas la route de
Memphis on y va si tu pouvais avoir l'identité de
la personnalité de ton choix laquelle serait-elle
Stevie du loft 1 AFFID Turner moi oh ouais ah
ouais ok mais galerie de ouf énorme maisveilleux
tu l'as tout tout toute la vie ou vraiment non
non non une petite une petite un petit weekend
ok ah quand même ouais ok le temps d'aller au
resto aller en boîte faire un show répondre
quelques commentaires sur un stade de clocharda
et pu trop c'est ça insulter de trois personnes
en story oui mais non mais elle a elle elle
a un répondant de ouf oui c'est vrai ah ouais
je dirais Drake dans dans la longévité de
carrière et dans la l'évolution de carrière
qu'il a eu le l'aspect mental làdedans par qu'
VI d'une série quand même pour ado et qu'il a
réussi à créer un empire comme ça j'aimerais
juste savoir ce qu'il y a dans sa tête et et
comment tu réussis d'année en année à je
CIS que tu all me suivre mon second degré
ok j'aimerais cher une bouteill boute déjà ça se
prononce américain tu feras un blooper tu feras
une compile salut c'estic et qui est Mister V et
qui est ça Sacha Sacha mais je connais pas le nom
de famille Sacha ch chaud ok yo c'est Mister VI
IIC non c'est l'inverse ok on recommence yo c'est
IIC et Mister V et Sacha ah j'ai un truc dans
la gorge merde salut c'est Ivic sach exactement
salut c'est qui est Mister V qui est Sacha
show dans Pamel rose la série sur Canal let's
go y